4 de febrero del 2014
estaba entrenando y me ponen a hacer
saltos sobre vallas una valla es un
obstáculo como de este tamaño y me pide
mi entrenadora que salte arriba de esa
valla
en la última valla se me atoró el pie y
caigo al piso de rodillas
como cualquier otra caída me trató de
levantar pero esta vez no podía
fueron segundos que se sintieron como
horas dentro de mí me trató de volver a
levantar y no podía no me podía mover
desesperación llanto me tiró al piso y
viendo al cielo me pregunto será el fin
de mi carrera como deportista
el deporte nuestro no es solo eso que le
sucede a algunas personas el deporte
está muy cerca de nosotros sólo hace
falta quererlo ver es tu hijo que va
feliz a la clase de natación es tu
esposo o esposa que se levanta todos los
días motivado por ir al gimnasio y bajar
de peso son tus amigos que se juntan
para correr un 10k es un grupo de
estudiantes que sin saber ni hablar el
mismo idioma juegan fútbol eres tú que
te gusta jugar fútbol eres tú que te
gusta correr eres tú que te gusta nadar
es increíble como el deporte nos habla
cada quien en un lenguaje diferente golf
pádel atletismo natación gimnasia
béisbol en méxico el deporte también ha
tocado la puerta a aquellos que pueden
influenciar de una manera más positiva
la salud la educación y las leyes
según datos dados por la unicef méxico
somos el país número uno en obesidad
infantil
uno de cada tres adolescentes entre 12 y
19 años padecen sobrepeso y obesidad
esto quiere decir que 4.1 millones de
escolares
padecen este problema
qué estamos haciendo dónde están las
ganas de prevenir la obesidad infantil
dónde están las ganas de prevenir la
diabetes deporte y bien lo dijo nelson
mandela
el deporte tiene el poder de cambiar el
mundo tiene el poder de inspirar le
habla a la juventud en el lenguaje que
solo ellos entienden el deporte crea
esperanza donde se ha perdido la fe
el deporte toco mi puerta cuando era muy
chica a los 8 años
les cuento un poco mi historia a los 8
años
entro al colegio y mis papás me piden
que escoge un deporte pues yo he decido
que el atletismo se viene en el torneo
intercolegial más importante del año y
la entrenadora me inscribe en la prueba
de salto de longitud entre otras pruebas
pues resulta que rompo el récord de la
prueba y la entrenadora se acerca con
mis papás y les dice su hija tiene el
potencial de algún día llegar a hacer
algo por el deporte pero va a ser un
largo camino tienen que ser muy
pacientes y tienen que esperar a que yo
la vaya desarrollando a su ritmo de
hecho esta es una foto de la primera
competencia y esta es una foto de mi
última competencia y como pueden ver no
mucho ha cambiado las mismas caras
cuántas oportunidades se nos presentan
así en la vida probablemente muchas unas
las dejamos pasar porque sentimos que no
están destinadas a ser nuestras otras
hay algo dentro de nuestro corazón que
nos dice aprovecha esta oportunidad no
pierdes nada y lo más importante es que
uno tiene la libertad de escuchar su voz
interna
en la universidad participó
representando a méxico en juegos
panamericanos ahí tengo la oportunidad
de conocer a la campeona olímpica de
beijing 8 de beijing 2008 en la prueba
de salto de longitud maurren maggi yo le
pregunto a marín que como le había hecho
ella para ganar una medalla olímpica y
me dice ivonne sigue tu camino
seguir mi camino qué significa eso yo
sabía que yo era responsable de las
acciones que hacía y si quería llegar al
pico de la montaña que era juegos
olímpicos iba a tomar absolutamente todo
de mí iba a tener que ser como un león
cuál es la diferencia entre un perro y
un león me platique a una amiga una
fábula un perro si tú le enseñas un
hueso y se lo avienta
el perro va por él si se lo pones aquí
lo mastica lo saborea un león en cambio
si tú la avienta es un hueso lo ve si tú
se lo pones lo huele él sabe que la
presa final eres tú no el hueso
todo hizo clic dentro de mí yo tenía que
ser como un león y no podía estar
distraída con tantos huesos aunque la
realidad nada hizo clic para la gente a
mi alrededor
ivonne estás loca juegos olímpicos
nombre iván en méxico no tenemos
infraestructura para esas cosas iban
mejor deja eso para las europeas y las
gringas y vos no pierdas tu tiempo
además nadie nadie ha ido nunca en
méxico en la prueba de salto de longitud
ivonne se unió la gente es alto longitud
tiene las piernas bien largas y van
mejor y a casa te
la verdad es que no los juzgo
según la federación olímpica
internacional en el mundo hay 7 mil
millones 350 mil personas de las cuales
si quieres ya las olimpiadas tú
posibilidades 0.0001 por ciento y si
hablamos en estadísticas de méxico si
juntamos
10 estadios azteca 25 estadios de los
tigres llenos
solamente iría una persona una en un
millón
y aun cuando todas las estadísticas
estuvieran en mi contra los números
decían que estaba loca
yo me pregunte iván porque no creemos
donde están las ganas de salir adelante
como mexicanos donde están las ganas de
abrir caminos de probar cosas nuevas
lo importante no es tanto lo difícil de
una situación sino la actitud que se
tiene ante ella
y aquí regreso al momento de mi recuerdo
cuando estaba tirada viendo el piso
viendo el cielo esperando sin poderme
mover
llega una ambulancia por mí me llevan al
hospital
y en el hospital el doctor me dice
ivonne tu lesión es muy grave no sé si
vayas a poder volver a saltar
quiere realmente seguir con tu carrera
como deportista yo dentro de mí sabía
cuál era la respuesta y le dije claro
que sí y claro que quiero y me hice muy
bien voy a ver qué puedo hacer pero por
lo pronto tienes que traer una férula de
toda tu pierna derecha y no te vas a
poder mover en un rato van a ser
alrededor de seis meses y a lo mejor
después necesitará cirugía en ese tiempo
alejandro mi esposo
me pide matrimonio y nos vamos a vivir a
houston yo sabía que los mejores
entrenadores del mundo estaban allá y
como la vida me estaba llevando para
allá los tenía que ir a buscar
llegó a la universidad de houston a
buscar al coach y es donde encuentras a
un entrenador de atletismo pues en una
pista ahí voy a la pista caminando llego
veo a un entrenador ahí afuera y yo dije
muy probablemente ese es él el coach de
yes llegó y me dice hola y le digo hola
soy bon de méxico hago el salto de
longitud y quiero entrenar con ustedes y
me dice se ríe espérame tantito quien te
recomiendo con nosotros cuál es tu mejor
marca platican un poco más de ti cuánto
mides cuánto pesas empezamos a platicar
un poco él y yo y me dice yo te hablo yo
te digo si puedes entrenar con nosotros
pasa una semana dos semanas tres semanas
cuatro semanas no sé nada de él yo con
alejandro mi amor que hago lo que hago
no me ha hablado el entrenador y me dice
espérate igual tienes una férula muy
apenas te puedes mover y además tienes
que esperarte a que vivamos en houston
entonces después de nuestra boda
llegamos a houston y llegó a la
universidad a las 7 de la mañana
7 la mañana no veía a nadie 89 oye pues
donde aquí la gente aquí ahora se
empieza ok entonces a las 9 empiezo a
preguntar por el entrenador coach ellas
conocen al coach de íes y nadie lo
conocía pero si yo lo conocí aquí como
que nadie lo conocía y un atleta me dice
es que no no es coach de jess es coach
del s
yo lo estaba pronunciando mal en eso
llega el entrenador lo veo entrar se me
paga el corazón porque yo sabía que ese
momento iba a ser decisivo en mi vida yo
sabía que si me aceptaba ese momento la
iba a marcar porque iban a aumentar mis
probabilidades de buscar mis sueños
jaibón qué haces aquí me dice y yo le
contesto de acuerdo en mi nombre
hola vengo a entrenar y me dice esta
lista sí sí estoy lista muy bien mi
corazón latiendo a mil por hora nos
salimos afuera a la pista y estando
afuera están ahí
carl lewis y su entrenador tom teles que
es el entrenador que es el papá de mi
entrenador considerado el mejor
entrenador de todos los tiempos y carl
lewis tiene nada más y nada menos que
nueve medallas olímpicas de oro yo me le
quería ir a abrazar pero dije no
compórtate
llegó y me dicen te vamos a probar te
vamos a probar esta semana y vamos a ver
si tienes el potencial no te vamos a
hacer perder tu tiempo ni el nuestro me
pusieron a entrenar y a la semana se
acerca toma y me dice ivonne si tienes
el potencial para brincar arriba de 7
metros que es lo que me sitúa dentro de
una marca o una medalla olímpica pero no
sabes nada no sabes nada de técnica no
sabes absolutamente nada que tenemos que
corregir todo y yo por acá si quiere
decir que voy a mejorar le pregunto y me
dice sí si vas a mejorar si lo quieres
ver así
ahí estaba la oportunidad que yo estaba
buscando y quedaba solamente en mi
aprovecharla y exprimir esa oportunidad
sin sin importar cuál fuera el resultado
para bien o para mal
empieza el año 2015 el año más difícil
de toda mi vida y vuelve lo hacer no así
no vuelve a correr 200 veces está mal
otra repetición otra sentadilla llegaba
llorando yo creo que todos los días en
mi casa ahí mi esposo fue una gran pieza
para mí porque me mantuvo fuerte y
terminando se la temporada
me vuelvo a lastimar
otra vez me vuelvo a lastimar quedaban
13 meses para juegos olímpicos
el entrenador me dice imán tenemos que
parar no podemos hacer nada te volviste
a lastimar
y algo dentro de mí me decía no puedes
tirar la toalla tu camino no está
terminado a un dios por alguna razón no
quería que me rindiera y quería que
pasara por esas situaciones tan
difíciles para lo que estaba por venir
el 2016 empezamos los entrenamientos se
integra al equipo andrews y esta es una
foto con ambos de mis entrenadores y en
la primera competencia del año rompo el
récord mexicano de pista bajo techo
brinco a la mejor marca de mi vida seis
meses después de estar lastimada después
voy a voy a la sala a una competencia
florida y brinco 6 metros 52 centímetros
a mi me pedían 6 puntos 76 metros 70
centímetros para ir a los juegos
olímpicos estaba a 18 centímetros de dar
la marca olímpica
tuve una competencia más en la
universidad de rice y en esta
competencia salto nada más y nada menos
que 6.69 6 metros con 79 centímetros 1
centímetro que me separaba de juegos
olímpicos o no juegos olímpicos la
última competencia que me quedaba era en
monterrey aquí en mi casa con mi familia
con mi gente en mi ciudad en mi país con
mis amigos
y yo me acuerdo que sería llovía y
llovía y llovía y llovía
y pues tú no puedes controlar eso tú
solamente puedes controlar lo que pasa
dentro de ti y yo no iba a dejar de
aprovechar esa oportunidad aún y cuando
no supiera cuál es cuál iba a ser el
resultado aún y cuando nadie me
garantizaba que iba a tener un buen
resultado
empieza la competencia de repente diez
minutos antes de que empezara deja de
llover se abre el sol se abren las nubes
y sale el sol
empieza el primer el primer salto nos
dan tres saltos de eliminatoria y tres
saltos de final primero segundo tercer
salto de la eliminatoria pasamos a la
final cuarto y esto es lo que sucedió en
el quinto salto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no lo habíamos logrado y digo lo
habíamos logrado porque este no es un
trabajo solamente mío este es un trabajo
en equipo es un trabajo que es primero
de dios que me dio la oportunidad de mi
esposo que me apoyo en las malas de mi
familia de mis papás que me educaron y
le abrieron la puerta al deporte en mi
vida de mis hermanos que me vieron
crecer de mi familia de mis amigos de
mis entrenadores este es un trabajo en
equipo
y la experiencia en río fue una de las
mejores experiencias de mi vida me di
cuenta que las oportunidades se pueden
encontrar en todo tipo de momentos pero
también las oportunidades se encuentran
en los errores en los fracasos en las
enfermedades es sólo cuestión de ti ver
qué actitud vas a tomar ante esa
adversidad mi camino aún no termina me
estoy preparando para las siguientes
olimpiadas en tokio en el 2020 pero
ahora con una mucha mayor motivación en
abril alejandro y yo vamos a hacer papas
y estamos esperando nuestro primer hijo
ojalá que siempre que estén ante una
adversidad sepan que los obstáculos son
parte del proceso ojalá que se atrevan a
decir yo puedo ojalá se den cuenta que
él no es posible no existe todo es
posible la mayor satisfacción en la vida
es encontrar el porqué de tu vida el
sentido de actuar el deporte no es
solamente algo físico es un
transformador de vidas por eso yo hoy
los invito a que vivan conmigo la magia
del deporte muchas gracias
[Aplausos]